we started off by talking about energy
and that complete one-for-one
relationship between the size of the
economy and the amount of energy
generated so let's check back in look
what's happened happening since 1970
here's where we worth energy use up
until the first Earth Day here's what's
been happening in the years since we are
decoupling profoundly the growth of our
economy the growth of our society and
our prosperity from the total amount of
joules or BTUs that you need to generate
that economy our economy is about 25
percent bigger than it was at the end of
the Great Recession our energy use is
essentially flat all throughout that
time the added good news here is that
largely because of the fracking
revolution where we're burning less coal
and using more natural gas to generate
electricity
our total greenhouse gas emissions are
actually now trending downward over time
and that red line is really interesting
it comes from a data source that takes
into account the carbon generated by all
the products that we import so this
really is the accurate picture of the
carbon footprint of the American economy
and I think it is past its peak it's
trending down and I will take anyone's
bet that we're not going to hit that
high point ever again or at least for
the next ten years now I want to say
this really clearly this line is not
going down quickly enough I am NOT
encouraging any kind of complacency here
but we have finally decoupled growing
our economy from generating greenhouse
gases in a pretty deep way